cette reconnaissance sont là chaque jour
à 20h au balcon de nombreux français
emmanuel macron qui re tweetent ses
vidéos sur son compte personnel en ça
vous inspire quoi doit revoir ça je sais
pas comment dire ça gentiment
ça m'inspire ça m'inspire la tristesse
en fait je me dis qu'il a rien compris
c'est à dire c'est des gestes dans ces
personnes ont besoin c'est pas 2 c'est
pas de musique et encore moins de bons
mots est aujourd'hui fort allez la
reconnaissance qu'elles soient
financières qu'elle soit en termes de
matériel la reconnaissance en termes de
matériel ça paraît quand même le minimum
parce que on peut pas envoyer des
combattants au feu sans équipement de
protection c'est absolument impossible
on imaginerait jamais cela de la part de
pompiers ou la part de militaires donc
il est normal que le personnel des
hôpitaux exige époque des hôpitaux
d'ailleurs des ehpad
enfin il ya plein de des prisons il ya
plein de domaines où on est concerné par
ce problème de matériel donc ça c'est
effectivement le minimum mais après
comme je les dis il ya des
revendications du personnel des hôpitaux
représenté par un comité de défense de
l'hôpital
et voilà ça serait bien de leur délivrer
autre chose que des bonbons on sait que
depuis un mois enfin en parlons
l'hôpital public a souvent manifesté il
ya des grèves dans les services d
urgence pour réclamer plus de moyens
aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à une
épidémie va dire sans précédent mais en
tout cas sans précédent sur les deux
dernières décennies y voir le dernier
siècle
voilà entre les revendications qui
pouvait y avoir ces derniers mois et
aujourd'hui dans la pratique de ce qui
se passe actuellement face à cette crise
inédite
comment ça se passe écoutez ça se passe
pour l'instant bien grasse grâce à tout
le monde
grâce aux aux infirmières aux aides
soignants aux agents hospitaliers aux
agents techniques aux médecins à
l'administration aux directeurs tout le
monde
du bas en haut de l'échelle travaillent
d'arrache-pied donc ça se passe plutôt
bien mais c'est au prix de ces un coût
humain et un coût social qui est
important pour ces personnes là qui ne
voient parfois pas leur famille depuis
des semaines
ou en tout cas plusieurs jours donc on y
arrive
après il est évident qu'il faudra faire
un geste pour ces personnes-là ces
combattants du feu
c'est quand même pas normal que pour
l'instant l'aurait deux adressés que des
mots encore des mots toujours des mots
et qu'il y ait pas eu de geste alors
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de promesses pour
le milieu industriel
ce que je comprends très bien il ya
aucun problème mais ça serait bien de
faire un geste aussi pour ces personnels
qui ont des revendications qui ont été à
peine écouté n'est certainement pas
satisfaites